well the first person in the uk and more
than that in the world
to receive the pfizer biontech vaccine
outside of trials was
ninety-year-old grandmother of four
margaret keenan as you saw there
right here in coventry and the nurse who
gave her the jab
was mae parsons and she is here with me
hello
to you may what a day for
margaret for the hospital but but for
you just tell me
what it was like it's been all
excitement
and the sense of pride that we could
actually
provide this vaccination to our patient
is
something that is so positive amongst
the negative things that's happened this
year
i think i think we're all looking
forward to actually giving our
vulnerable
patients in the community to have some
protection from this devastating virus
and i think as a nurse that's
really important for me knowing that
they're going to be safe they're going
to be protected
and i think it's just first step for
giving everyone a sense of normality
soon hopefully once this vaccine rolls
up to everyone
that is everybody's hope isn't it this
is what this is
all about when did you find out that it
was going to be you
delivering that world first well it was
last week it's only because
i have been doing the flu jab and the
pure vaccinator program in uhcw
where we have trained nurses to actually
deliver the flu job every year
and this year i've done 226 jobs amongst
my peers and
because i've had all of that practice
they've deemed that
i've had the most numbers then i would
be able to kind of deliver it without
any problems and because of the practice
i've
had so yes that's probably why it was
so i was apparently the most prolific
flu jabber in uacw
so you're well experienced but given the
significance of this moment
did you have shaky hands at all not
while i was doing it i was hoping that
it wasn't shaking at all because
for me it was the experience that kind
of helped me through the process because
i know that that's what we're supposed
to be doing
and the fact that we've had that local
policy anyway we're doing it in and out
day in and out and 20 years of
experience helped me to do that
i think the shakes and the nerves were
afterwards when people were asking me
how about how it felt
and obviously the overwhelming kind of
pride for our trust to be the first to
actually deliberate in the world
is something momentous really
historically and for the nursing staff
here
what does it mean so for me i think it's
it's a sense of pride for all of our
staff here and all of the people has
actually come together and put all these
things
to make it possible for today to happen
i think it's just a sense of achievement
for all of us that's done it
and obviously my filipino british
community and the filipinos around the
world
and i'm really really proud to say that
you know we do our contributions to the
healthcare
system around the globe not just in the
uk so i'm really proud of that
and as a frontline nhs worker you will
be eligible
for the vaccine in these first stages as
well what will that
mean for you in terms of giving you
reassurance as you go about your job
i think that's going to be a positive
thing i said to everyone that i've
spoken to you that the first thing that
i get offered i'll have it because i
know that then it will give me
protection
if i won't get it that means then i
won't pass it to my family and my
friends and my especially my patients
are already vulnerable anyway
so that for me is ultimately the goal to
protect everyone around me as well as
myself
that must have been hanging over you
after all of these months every time
that you go home
and every time you come here into the
hospital particularly with the fear of
asymptomatic
yes spread it has and i think the first
wave of the pandemic is particularly
stressful because
the worry is there thinking that you're
taking it home and you know
and giving it to someone inadvertently
and i think that's why everyone
in this hospital and all over the world
is kind of concentrating on their ppes
and their
infection control and washing their
hands and over ending up with cracked
hands and everything but it doesn't
matter as long as we're not giving it
and passing it on i think that's a
really important thing
yeah not passing it on both here but
also not taking it home
to yes definitely and that was the
biggest worry for me because obviously
you wouldn't know
until they have it how they will react
to it because it's so new no one kind of
really knows what happens so it's almost
kind of like a trial test so
everyone can have it but then everyone
will have different kind of effects or
have different
experiences of the virus so that's the
main thing for me to not take it home
and pass it on to my patients really
and for the vaccine today how was it
for margaret did she feel any discomfort
any
kind of side effects afterwards in the
immediate aftermath no
so basically yesterday we've had i met
with her yesterday and explained to her
about the
lots of attention because it's going to
be historical event
and i said to her that i just wanted to
make sure that she's okay and that she
didn't even feel it
well that's just new to you which is
really good and i think that's a really
good feedback in terms of
injections and if people are actually
quite anxious about getting injections
it doesn't
sometimes it doesn't hurt you don't even
feel it so most of the people that i've
kind of given
injections today i asked them did you
feel it and then they didn't so which is
good
really good and just tell us what the
coming days and weeks
have in store for you well um we're
going to be obviously running this now
the door is open we're going to be
running the program seamlessly seven
days a week so i'm hoping to contribute
as well as
my other peer vaccinators and as well as
nurses are going to be
putting in their times to actually make
this work and actually get all the
vulnerable patients that we have across
the community to get their vaccinations
so yeah it's going to be a busy week
easy month but
it's all for a good course it's all
worth it may parsons thank you